Porque a minha intranquilidade deve-se ao facto desta experiência com o enfermeiro que bateu-me imenso nas mãos.
E depois acho que um bom profissional não põe a culpa no doente.
E depois estava a dizer que eu é que afastei a mão da outra enfermeira.
pôs logo e vê-se perfeitamente que entrou na veia logo.
Não é andar com o bico à procura, ainda por cima numa zona que é fácil de acesso.
Isto tem sido bastante fácil.
Isso pôs-me intranquila.
Também não acho que falar muito alto e ser muito expansivo traga tranquilidade.
Acho que uma voz calma para estas situações é o ideal.
fazer exercícios que eu já costumo fazer que é respiração profunda respirar, reter e depois deitar fora o ar pensando sempre que estou num riacho que estou a nadar numa água muito quente e que estou numa experiência eu associo sempre as experiências aquáticas a coisas boas mas o verbo também é importante então eu situo-me num riacho com águas mordas
em que estou tranquilamente a nadar.
E vou fazendo a respiração a pensar nisso.
Sim, sinto-me mais tranquila.
Foi importante, depois a outra enfermeira, quando colocou, com assertividade, porque a assertividade traz tranquilidade.
Ela foi muito assertiva, não vacilou.
Isso traz-nos tranquilidade.
Também me trouxe tranquilidade ver o doutor David como vai operar.
Uma amiga, que temos uma amiga comum, que é anestesista, também foi cá cumprimentar.
São coisas que são amistosas e boas.